my dad rented out like this huge suite
for all my girlfriends to party all
night at this hotel
and he was like you guys can do whatever
you want but the one rule is
no boys like no boys allowed and we're
like okay okay of course no boys
like 30 seconds later like every boy in
town like
hello and welcome to the roast of your
teenage self podcast
i am your host your roast coming
queen virginia high school league
one act play competition finalist
and former high school student elise
morales
and with us today guys we have
very funny and talented comedian actress
host
of the soup on e and graduate
of albemarle high school please welcome
jade cut a prank
hi guys i'm so happy to be here i'm sad
that i didn't bring my holographic vest
from my show choir days you were a show
choir girl we haven't even gotten into i
know i'm sorry i thought i'd just jump
right in
like you know i had vests so it was the
whole thing so
alba mural high school public or private
public public high school but i also
know because you told me before we
started recording
that you did homeschooling for the last
yeah last year i really wanted to do the
whole acting dancing uh thing and my
parents were very supportive and so i
got to do a lot of local theater and
then i went to like summer camp in new
york
so it was a career move it wasn't
because usually when i hear homeschool i
immediately am like
religious no not even close i wish it
was like my parents just didn't want me
around the devil kids oh
yeah no i would i want to do from really
really early age and my parents were
always really supportive and
i just i think i really clashed um with
my high school at the time like i was i
was just figuring out that i like wanted
to be on broadway
and i got it in charlottesville virginia
you know like it was just that
and i only had like a few really really
close friends at the time and so
it was a good decision for me i think so
when you were
in public school were you doing you were
doing show choir were you doing the
plays yeah i was doing show choir
i was i did damn yankees i was lola it
was like the highlight of my high school
um amazing theater career um but i was
your book editor
i think one of the photos you have is
like me like turned around is
like from yearbook yeah yeah look at
that
look at one of my butts still had
elasticity look
at that so this was it you put this
in the yearbook as your book i think we
i think we tried to i don't know if it
actually made it but i remember
this day we were like all taking photos
of ourselves in the staff to be like
sneakily put it in you know people
always ask like what was your
superlative and i'm like i couldn't be
your book editor and like be a
superlative that just felt like a little
too you could sly slip in maybe like one
cute butt pick but to give yourself best
hair would be too much
too much look how low ryder those pants
are remember when pants were like not
above your belly button yeah i'm gonna
say are these
boot cut wow i didn't even notice how
high
up they were um i was really preppy in
high school like
because i was in virginia you know so
like really preppy in high school and
actually really preppy in college too
like i would double up the
the collared shirts like i did that look
yeah we have another picture that you
sent where you're wearing suspenders
and like a fedora moment going on this
was actually a really big moment for me
dude because
it was spirit day and i think it was
like i was doing like a janet jackson
thing and
you see how my boots are like pointing
the pants are way too short once again
but um
the boots being pointy was like a big
deal like this is when sex in the city
first came out and like
wearing pointy heels was like i remember
walking through the hallways wearing
those boots and just being like
i am such a badass like i did it i'm
doing it
i feel like i still have such an
affinity for like the clothing items
that i
bought when i was in high school that i
was like this is gonna change
things for me like it does though it
does like people really like
one day of high school is like so many
days of an adult life
so many things happen you know per one
day but yeah like
what a [ __ ] nerd look at me that it's
so funny because so i grew up in
northern virginia and i swung the
opposite way with my fashion i was like
a hot topic like emo
kid girl and i felt like that was the
two
ways that you can exist in virginia is
like you're either
north face and uggs yeah oh it's true
it's true or you're working like that's
it
yes or you're wearing a cape to school
like that's the two it's
funny because my best friend from high
school who i
is the only like i only have two friends
that i'm still friends with now in real
life
um kitty lion she's actually like in the
industry as well
she was like angel wings like she just
dressed so wildly
and she actually had a like pepto-bismol
pink cadillac
that she drove around town it was a
really small town so everybody knew her
car
she was like so cool look how cool she
was like and i was like preppy like i'm
wearing a cross necklace
like what well but honestly uh
really inspiring to have a preppy and a
girl who wears angel wings
going to concerts together and and
remaining friends
yeah i also was like very big into um
nail polish
arts and crafts i don't know if you can
really see but i'm holding my nokia cell
phone which was this is my first cell
phone
ever ever ever and it's like i would do
this thing where i would cover it in
nail polish dots it would take me
hours like i would do like oh
my god i can't believe you just said
that because i
literally have a memory of sitting in
my friend this was when i was littler
and i lived in la until i was 12 we i
was like sitting in my friend laura
jean's
a house and we were meticulously
painting
yeah our nokia cell phones with like
whatever different nail polish she had
and then it chips off
like i still have that nokia cell phone
cover i like kept it
like just a little cover handle that
would come off this was the thing at my
high school the razer flip phone was
really big do you remember that
of course i missed that so it came in
pink and silver
and at my school if you were dating
if like i would have the pink one right
and if i was dating a boy who had the
silver one
we would switch battery packs so then
when you were using your pink cell phone
it would have his silver battery pack
and it was like
watch out world i am taken see like that
there's gonna be so much stuff like that
with our kids that we're not gonna
understand like
also how lucky were we that we got to
just be kids
and not like online like the stuff that
we did
and got away with like like i cannot
believe it
there are so many things that like i'm
just so
glad that all of the videos that we made
for our high school drama class like do
not exist online
oh well those i wish we had but i'm
talking more about like you know like
parting in the woods and like naked and
all that stuff like me and kitty we were
pretty crazy like
so that's a question i had for you
because so you're going to call it or
you're going
you're going to high school in
charlottesville which has
a major university yeah kind of at its
center so what's that like are you
going to college parties what's your
relationship to the college well i was
like a very horny kid anyway because i'm
from brazil originally and
i moved to charlottesville virginia
actually when i was 12. so i was like an
immigrant like i didn't speak english
like
and so by the time i was in high school
and i like could speak english i was
just like
kind of a monster we partied with like
high school kids all the time i also
i saw rocky horror picture show way too
early and became like
way too over sexual actually you have a
photo
um from the night we went to see rocky
horror picture show like we were all
dressed up as the characters
and then we went to a college party
we're like partying with our college
friends like
oh my god so we're like i was gonna ask
about the choker but it makes sense
i was like magenta and we used to hang
out at this like
literally like this crack house with
these college students like i still live
there
and that's us just like parting with
them if you
were a teen theater kid and you didn't
dress as magenta at least
once like were you even really a theater
kid yeah like do you know all the words
to rocky horror picture show and rent
or you don't ugh i remember the first
time seeing both of those things rocky
horror picture show and rent and just
being like
i am magenta i am maureen this is
what will guide me moving forward in my
life yeah
people still make fun of me but i don't
care like literally they were so
formative to me and i remember seeing
rant like
like in college the first time after i'd
seen it so many times in high school
and understanding so many of the parts
that i didn't get it's so funny because
i'm doing like
i'm like 16 doing like the whole la vie
poem like rap
having done none of the things not
knowing any of that like yeah me too i'm
like
don't do some intimidation it's so funny
how
big rent is as like a high school or at
least
for me like as a high school theater kid
how big rent was when the themes are
like
have nothing to do with my suburban high
school life at all
we don't need to pay for anything we
like we've never met anyone with hiv
like they're not we're not on the
streets but like i craved being in new
york
so intensely like all throughout high
school and
getting to like go there and do these
like camps that's when i started to meet
people that were like me you know like i
remember seeing a guy shimmy once and i
was like
a guy shimmy like i found my headband
like you know meeting gay people for the
first time like
you know there weren't any in our town
and so um it was really important to me
so let's talk about that decision so
what what led to you was it did it come
from you like you went to your parents
and were like i would like to be
homeschooled so that i can start to
pursue
yeah there was this big theater in our
in our town called live arts and they
used to be like this tiny little theater
um and now they're like this big
beautiful building in charlottesville
they do these like major productions
and i started getting really involved
with them in the summer and then
realized that i could like be in a play
and make money but it would be like
impossible
yeah like it would be impossible to do
it and be in school and i was really
miserable in school i was like getting
in arguments with teachers like
you know i'm kind of a know-it-all even
though i don't really know a lot um
so i would get in fights with teachers
and i there was just some animosity of
like i wanted to leave i didn't really
want to be like parting in the woods all
night
like i didn't want to really be like i
felt like a sheep like basically and
um i didn't want to just like get
married and have kids and that's like
what
a lot of my friends were like and so
like when i met kitty and kitty and i
became really close and then this girl
named amanda and i got really close
we were like really the three that got
out basically of charlottesville
with charlottesville being a college
town i feel like it's probably really
easy for someone to
just stay in charlottesville it's a
great town like now i go back and i'm
like oh i would live here like my
sister's still there
a lot of my friends are still there but
it was just like oppressive to me at the
time i was like i need to venture
like i need to get out you know my last
year of high school was basically like
online classes and tutors that i cheated
with and
so how yeah how did that work did you
respond well okay
yeah it was all online and then i would
have like i would have to like go places
to take like major tests
or um yeah stuff like that and then i
remember when i graduated like i didn't
do the walk and everything with my class
it was like a rainy day and my sister
and i went to albemarle high school
and she was like jade cataprida and like
she gave me the
the the what's it called my god the
diploma
and we opened it up and my last name was
spelled wrong and we just started
dying laughing we were like on the floor
like they can't even get this
right like we're freaking out
hello everyone today's episode of the
roast of your teenage
self podcast is brought to you by mint
mobile if you're still using one of the
big wireless providers this year
have you ever asked yourself what you're
paying for between expensive retail
stores
inflated prices and hidden fees you're
being taken advantage of hun because
they
know you'll pay enter mint mobile
mint mobile provides the same premium
network coverage you're used to
but at a fraction of the cost because
everything is
on line mint mobile saves on retail
stores
and overhead and then passes those
savings on
to you mint mobile makes it easy to cut
your wireless bill down to just
15 bucks a month
imagine it sounds crazy but it's true it
can happen it can happen for you
every plan comes with unlimited
nationwide talk and text
with mint mobile you can stop paying for
unlimited data that you'll never use
choose between plans with 3 8 or 12
gigabytes of 4g
lte and you can use your own phone with
any mint mobile plan to keep your same
phone number
and your same contacts in case you're
crushed from high school finally
realizes what a mistake it was not to go
to prom with you
they want to get in touch they've seen
you on instagram you're looking amazing
it's okay you still have their number
they still have your number it's all
good with mint mobile
ditch your old wireless bill and start
saving
with mint mobile to get
your new wireless phone for just 15
bucks a month and to get the plan
shipped to your door for free go to mint
mobile.com
teen self that's mint mobile dot com
slash teen self
cut your wireless bill down to 15 bucks
a month honey at mint
mobile.com teen self
um but that's that's virginia for you
i know and what a testament to your time
there you know it's like
like i [ __ ] left you i don't even
know who i am yeah you
had this conversation with your parents
were they on board immediately like okay
let's just get the
paperwork yeah they knew what i wanted
to do i was really driven to it you know
like i had really really good grades i
was very academic like as you can tell i
have very high energy i'm like
um and so i just wanted to put
that energy towards something that you
know i knew that i would want to be
doing
in taking the online classes as a
teenager
what did you feel like you like learned
stuff or was that just like a formality
that you had to deal with so that you
might i don't remember anything like
when people talk about i also like kind
of
skipped the whole part of like geography
and history stuff because i was like
kind of i was in brazil at the time so
when i came over like i didn't know and
i don't know a lot of like american
history
um yeah like
i was never good about taking tests like
under pressure i was really bad and i
also like
started to get to a point where i was
like very feminist i was like these
tests are made by white older men
like they don't get me you know um
that's i mean that's correct
but it wasn't wrong yeah i just was like
i just want a shimmy in new york like
and be like
carrie bradshaw like just let me be that
so did you do the s.a.t and stuff or
where you're like i don't need to
i did horribly on the sats i took them
twice
um i don't remember my score but they
were bad i wanted to go to nyu so bad
like i remember once we got arrested
because um
we trespassed we like broke into this
building and my friend peed off the roof
and we all got arrested and then i was
like
and what crying to the cops they're like
yeah
what like you're just getting a ticket
like it's not yeah we're not gonna tell
nyu
so did you where did you ultimately end
up going
i actually got into nyu but not into cap
the collaborative arts program of the
21st century which no longer even exists
um but i ended up going to emerson which
was actually like
life changing and like why i am where i
am today and
um it's such a lesson of like everything
happens for a reason
and like i remember falling to my knee
you know when you get the envelope and
it's not like a big
envelope was just like a letter and i
was like
in that year that like senior year that
you're doing
you're where you're like basically
waiting to go to
school to learn theater
what are you doing in the meantime are
you going up to new york and auditioning
you're doing these camps
like what what was your focus i was
doing dance like full time almost i went
to
hofstra a lot for like their dance camp
i did the cap 21 summer program two
years in a row
and then i was working full-time at live
arts doing plays on there i think at the
time i was doing
summer evening in des moines was a play
that i did in the fall
and then in the spring we did bat boy
which is still my favorite musical of
all time if you guys don't
please look it up yeah i was just doing
that and then i became really good
friends with like
kind of all these gay dudes in town like
these rich older gay dudes so i was just
like kind of partying and like
doing theater which was my dream you
know so what
that was my next question is what was
your social life like like
who i mean you have these two really
close friends who clearly get you
yeah who are the other people that
you're hanging out with
i kind of had the two girlfriends and we
had kind of like an alternative group of
friends that were like
into music and like theater and like
film and then also my sister and i were
really really close my sister's like a
year and a half
um not even younger than a year and a
half maybe or
i forget how far apart we are but yeah
we were close and
so them and then i hung out with my
parents a lot and
like i was bad but nobody really knew it
and actually there's a picture
there that you guys have we went to an
erd concert i was obsessed
obsessed with pharrell still am um he's
a vampire he doesn't age
um and we drove in with the with the
cadillac and they like invited us
backstage and we got to meet him and
they were like
you want to come to a strip club we're
like we're in high school so were you
good at like
getting away with the trouble that you
were doing yeah but we got like busted a
couple big times like first was the
peeing off the roof one and then
okay when i turned 16 my sister and i
were doing like one of those you know
there's like photo shoots where they can
take the images and they own them
like you pay a hundred dollars and then
they use them as like
cliff art or whatever and we're doing
one and he's like and the next one's
gonna be at this hotel we're like oh my
god exciting we get to the hotel
all my girlfriends are there my dad
rented out like this huge suite for all
my girlfriends to party all night at
this hotel
and he was like you guys can do whatever
you want but the one rule is
no boys like no boys allowed and we're
like okay okay of course
no boys like 30 seconds later like every
boy in town like
gets there we're wasted like we're being
teenagers we're like
running back and forth from the jacuzzi
to the room like there's beer
like so bad of course the cops come and
like put us in the line and one by one
we're like having to do a breathalyzer
like it was a nightmare and then like
everybody came to my parents house and
had to get picked up and i mean it seems
like your parents are very
cool by many standards we're very cool
yeah is that like a brazilian thing is
that like
is it yeah is it like more just
acceptable to have a big party
yeah i mean i was in trouble like
obviously because of the boy thing but
like
yeah i think like it's not a big deal to
drink in brazil and that's why there's
like less duis there's less like
you know people killed in drinking and
driving accidents like
i think a lot of the reason why we drink
in high school here it's because like
you can't
it's like the forbidden thing you know
so yeah and me and my friends i
when i think back to like the way we
would drink in high school because i
started drinking maybe around like 11th
grade
and we would drink like bacardi 151 like
the most like ever clear
in uh in like soup like it was like
i used to love hard rock or hard rock
the lemonade thing what was it called
mike's hard mic's hard
and now i drink those gross like uh what
are those like drinks everybody drinks
now
claws white flowers are basically mike's
hard lemonade like for grownups
that's the real t it's like they're they
there's no difference
i digress back to my high school days
now in this quarantine i just drink
white claws by myself and i'm like
but we would drink like such stupid
alcohol that was like not necessary like
we wouldn't just get like
beers and have beers as kids we would be
like we're gonna get the most
intense like shoe polish liquor we
possibly can
and then take shots of it until we puke
on our parents couch
like it was it was crazy our
relationship
we were so bad yeah i think we just
wanted to like it just it was a
different feeling you know what i mean
like to feel kind of out of control was
like exciting you know when you're a kid
you're like spinning around and that's
like your drug
and then in high school it just gets
real okay were your parents
because your dad didn't want you to have
boys at this party so were your parents
cool with you
dating in high school what was did you
have boyfriends what's going on there
i was i was disgusting i have so many
regrets uh um
i was just very like first i started
with like a really cute boyfriend that i
lost my virginity to and then broke up
with him and dated an [ __ ]
who like didn't care about me at all
forever and who would like i still
probably have some leftover trauma from
um and then i would just like yeah date
older guys who just wanted to have sex
and like
and then i dated a guy who worked at get
zooks actually he texted me today i
thought that was kind of funny um
he was like into weezer and had like a
piercing right here um
did you meet him at the mall there was
like a cool coffee shop in town at
downtown
like where all the cool actually my
friend kitty ended up working there but
like all the cool like alternative kids
used to work there
oh my god there was this boy who i
when i i moved from california to
virginia when i was in
seventh grade when i was 12. and there
was this boy in my class
named david who wore the like hot topic
pants that were like the giant
enormous pants that had chains on them
and like big pockets
and he had my whole heart
[Laughter]
is my heart in your pants right now or
it's such a thing but like it becomes
such a thing like you know how i'm
wearing that little like
floating cross that was like the thing
and
i remember we went to clarus and i stole
it and i'd never stolen anything in my
life and i have like a weird thing with
like telling
a lie like it's very difficult for me
which for acting is like
the whole thing but uh i stole it from
that cross from claire is the one i'm
wearing in that picture and i felt so
bad i went back and i told
the girl who was working there and she
was like i don't care just
i was like oh that's a lesson in life
oh my that's so funny because um when i
was in high school we also
there was like a rash of stealing from
claire's likes like
all people were stealing from claire's
and we all got caught
eventually and i got caught at the fair
oaks mall i was actually stealing from
somewhere else
i had graduated from stealing from
claire's i started stealing from
elsewhere
got picked up in bath and body works oh
my god we're
so obsessed with bath and body works
that's like another weird like virginia
thing
i got picked up at bath and body works
by the mall police
it was so sad
me and my friend they like took us into
the back they called my dad
they made me pick him up i actually i
had been stealing
a bra that had padding in it
and so then my dad came and i had to
like
explain that to him and they took a
picture of me with like the thing that i
stole so it was like me and this bra
it was horrible i stuffed my bra a lot
like you can see even in the photos that
you guys have like my boobs look
humongous like the one with harry
connick jr look at
like how much stuffed that's a stuffed
bra if i've ever [ __ ] seen one
it's so funny because when i was in high
school too i was
so concerned with the fact that i didn't
have big boobs and it like really
really me and it like loomed large in my
life
as like a big issue that i was gonna
have to deal with
and now it's like i could care less
that's why i get so sad when kids
like do anything that like really shaped
their life in high school because
it's such a trivial time that like you
should just enjoy and like
you know like people that peak in high
school like that's a down plunge
yes ever since then you know like it's
so important to like teach your kids in
high school to just like this is a time
that you're like it's building blocks
like it's just stepping stones it's not
who you're gonna be for the rest of your
life yet
you know it's such a delicate balance
between
like letting a high schooler like you
who clearly has like a
passion for something maybe make her own
path
and like have make a different choice
with how she's gonna do things while
also
reminding that high schooler like this
is not
everything you have so much growth to do
you're not like
like you you still should you know go to
emerson and go to college and do all
this and have a high school life
you don't feel like you need to make
every decision now yeah
i miss college i'm not gonna lie i loved
college
like high school was tough for me i was
really lost and like kind of trying to
find my way and
and then college i was like oh this skin
feels right yeah
well it seems like you were an
independent
person in general who really had a craft
that you
wanted to hone so it's like i imagine
that last year when you were in
homeschool
felt like you were just in like a
waiting a holding pattern
isn't it crazy to think about like how
long it takes us to get to
to get to where we want to be like let's
just say that
as the soup being like the peak of like
what i've always wanted to do right my
dream job
it's taken my entire life up to like
it's taken me 36 21 years
um from 21. to get to where i wanted to
be that's insane to think about like if
high school me
saw me now like i would be so proud it's
good i think it's good to take those
little moments you know
am i getting cheesy sorry oh no that's
beautiful i was gonna say that
if you were to talk to high school jade
what would you tell her now i would say
have less sex with gross dudes
um like especially less dudes um who
have hpv
yeah i would be like it's coming just
like keep working you know
like i don't know i wish i didn't have
so much like resentment for my high
school days like i wish i just would
have enjoyed it more
but i just yeah but when you feel when
when you're in there and you
feel so stuck like i just remember
feeling so trapped
by the fact that i had to be there every
day and i
wanted and you know like you it's like i
wanted to be doing
so much bigger stuff with my life and i
was like now i got
like why do i have to be in algebra why
also like why do people have to be in
algebra like i understand like
being studious and like teaching people
like routine and like hard work and
stuff like that but like
i feel like high school there should be
like financial classes that teach you
how to like get a credit card and like
worth
with a credit card like you should learn
how to cook for yourself like
you should learn about like renting you
know whatever i just think that
like the whole educational system in
high school is like so
misflopped yes i think that that's a
huge
part of also that like feeling of
resentment that the high school
experience leaves a lot of people in
because it's like
when you're in elementary school and
you're a little kid it's kind of like
you don't really have the tools to
recognize when stuff's [ __ ]
but when you're in high school now
you're smarter and you're like
this makes no sense why we're doing it
this way
like you still have to do it and do well
at it so it's like it's difficult you
know
but yeah like you finally reach the age
where you're able to be like
wait why do i need to learn this instead
of
this which is like i still don't know
what a 401k is
i would love to know where they teach
you like you know it's not worth to buy
clothes that's expensive when you're
this broke like oh yeah
i remember walking into virginia like i
have this very vivid memory
my first day of school in fifth grade
and i had this like little leather
backpack
just had crayons and a notebook in there
and this girl brandy walked up to me and
smelled me like sniffed me
and like it i like i remember what she
was wearing i remember every little
detail
so nuts um and then i
i don't i mean sorry i'm just confused
as to why she's
like i mean i was in virginia in a place
where people were like what's it like to
speak spanish i'm like
portuguese or like you know like what's
it like to wear shoes i'm like there
were no vines swinging in brazil
um yeah i think it was just such a clash
of
culture you know and then when i first
got to america i really wanted to be
american and then like by the end of
high school i was kind of like who am i
like you know and i just recently went
back to brazil and started to like
really find myself like
i had a big breakup went to brazil and
then
like the soup eventually happened and i
i honestly think it's because like i
needed to reconnect
and kind of get back to these roots that
i imagine you kind of
maybe put in a box for a little bit
especially in like early middle school
when you're like i'm not weird i'm just
like all of you i'm american i'm
american
like yeah okay jade i think that that is
a good
place for us to wrap it up though i do
feel like we could chat
forever and ever nice to like nice to
chat with someone i mean we're all so
isolated right now so
i know i know i hope i hope you continue
to
to thrive and quarantine and beyond and
for everyone who's listening
this has been the roast of your teenage
self podcast
you